البدايه من اخر التطورات في القدس المحتله
اذا اتخذ الطاقه الوزاريه الاسرائيليه
المصغر سلسله قرارات عقابيه ضد
الفلسطينيين شملت اغلاقه منزلي منفذ عمليه
القدس على الفور تمهيدا لهمه
ايضا
من الحق في تامين الوطني وعدم المنحهم
بطاقات الهويه الخاصه بسكان القدس
الاسلحه الناريه الاسرائيليين والتعزيز
الاجراءات الامنيه في المستوطنات
قليله من صدور
قالت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه الى الجيش اغلقه
منزل الشهيد خيري علقا منافذ عمليه القدس
المحتله التي اسفرت على مقتل سبعه
مستوطنين واصابه اخرين بالجروح وتداول
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه صورا لافرادا
من الجيش يستخدمون ادوات لحام لاغلاق
المنزل وعزله كليا
اعتقلت والده ووالده وشقيقه منافذ عمليه
القدس خير علقم في وقت سابق